[Musica]
come non c'è una parola che viene dalle
calatino
co.re.co vuol dire insieme e rare vuol
dire essere attaccato quindi
coerenza ha un significato in qualche
modo fisico essere attaccato essere
insieme
essere coeso storia il termine viene
usato in italiano ma anche in inglese in
altre lingue con un altro significato
più come in senso lato con una qualità
comportamentale morale
ci sono degli studi di psicologia che
dicono che la coerenza nei genitori
verso nel rapporto padri figli a un ha
un'influenza molto importante e positiva
quando i figli crescono e quindi nelle
loro relazioni interpersonali e adesso
diciamocelo tanto facile essere coerenti
quando siamo definiti che sono teenager
bus ecco parliamo di
coerenza
coerenza e armonia coerenza e logicità
coerenza non vuol dire essere coerente
non vuol dire che è una persona deve
pensare sempre la stessa cosa durante la
sua vita un po cambiata idea però deve
essere consistente con se stesso nel
senso pensare ed esprimere fisicamente
e anche a parole la stessa cosa di
essere se stesso la coerenza è una
qualità molto importante delle persone
ma l'accoglienza è anche una qualità
molto importante in natura non tutti
sanno che è una proprietà della luce è
legata al fatto che le particelle di
luce i cosiddetti fotoni quando
viaggiano da un punto per esempio del
sole fino alla nostra finestra e
illuminano quel pezzo di mobile che ci
si è dimenticati spolverate
non si muovono con un raggio retto ma
sono energia
sono
sono campi elettromagnetici e si muovono
come delle onde
avete presente abbiamo del mare la
stessa cosa allora facciamo l'esempio
delle onde del mare per capire la
coerenza immaginate che ci sono due onde
che partono da due punti diversi però
sono esattamente identiche hanno la
stessa ampiezza la stessa fase camminano
si muovono nella stessa direzione
finché a un certo punto si scontrano
se le due onde hanno percorso
esattamente lo stesso cammino nel
momento in cui si scontrano e molto
probabile che le due cresce mano chi è
un'assoluta altro allora il loro
il loro picco si amplificherà se invece
per un certo motivo una delle due onde
arriva un po più ricordo ritardo
abbastanza in modo che il picco di una
ma a finire sul minimo dell'altra si
cancella
stiamo tornando a questo punto di
interferenza fra le onde quando le onde
eseguiamo ad esattamente lo stesso
cammino allora si dicono coerenti
esattamente la stessa cosa si può a
questo punto
traslare a quello che è l'esempio della
luce quindi prendiamo queste tre onde
del mare e torniamo alle onde ai nostri
due fotoni alla dice quando i due fotoni
e queste particelle di luce partono dal
dal sole si muovono come due romance si
propagano nello spazio fino ad arrivare
da noi si hanno percorso esattamente la
stessa distanza sono rimasti in quello
che si dice che in fase e hanno la
stessa ampiezza e tutto allora nel
momento sono coerenti e nel momento in
cui li sovrapponiamo in qualche modo noi
siamo amplificando quello che è il
segnale della sorgente iniziale da cui
sono partiti e in questo segnale che
andremo a misurare e quindi amplificato
sommato dei bottoni ci sono incapsulati
e delle informazioni sulla società
inizia ma voi direte ma perché così
importante perché è importante che la
luce sia coerente cosa cambiano in tutti
i giorni ma immaginiamo di trovarci in
montagna una nottata in cielo terzo
nottata stupenda usciamo fuori e
osserviamo il cielo stellato conteremo
state un po di tempo più o meno 6 mila
stelle
questo è quello che si può vedere a
occhio nudo anche qui per esempio qui in
cile nel deserto di atacama
più qui abbiamo anche la via lattea
pesto prendo ma non la barbie con
un'altra volta
le stelle
noteremo che le stelle che stiamo
osservando seppur sappiamo che sono
delle stelle giganti sono sempre dei
conti è un punto la stella più vicina ma
in un punto anche la super gigante
betelgeuse che l'anno scorso come già
finita su tutti i giornali
la stella che sta nella costellazione di
orione che per qualche motivo
scientifico ha perso un po di luminosità
e tutti di spaventare le stesse per
esplodere non vi preoccupate non esplode
e un punto pure quella
e voi mi direte vabbè però gli stiamo
guardando con gli occhi col telescopio
di casa è normale ci amiamo i telescopi
da 8 10 metri per guardarvi no è sempre
un punto la maggior parte degli oggetti
anche osservati con i telescopi che
abbiamo al giorno d'oggi i grandi di
giganti della tv occhi giganti della
terra da otto dieci nati sono dei punti
stiamo costruendo un telescopio che a
uno specchio da 40 metri
la maggior parte degli oggetti son
talmente lontani che resteranno comunque
definiti e allora cosa serve se vogliamo
osservarli in maniera più più risolta se
vogliamo veramente osservare una stella
come stiamo secondo il sole ma se per
esempio vogliamo
osservare un vulcano su giove
avremmo bisogno di un telescopio 100
metri
se volessimo osservare un nucleo di una
galassia
grassi per bene
con un telescopici server abate un caso
di più o meno 400 maria adesso la
immaginate lo specchio di 400 metri
trasportando
intanto a livello ingegneristico e molto
e molto difficile ottenere le stesse
strutture
immaginate trasporto cioè e poi
economicamente non è sostenibile
io allora
usiamo la coerenza
se io sia con questa proprietà della
luce di cui abbiamo parlato un inizio
alla coerenza
allora le cose cambiano perché non serve
più questo dire per i telescopi giganti
da 104 100 metri sfruttando la coerenza
della luce passato istruire non ti
telescopi piccoli da 12 metri io ho
delle antenne neanche un po più grande
per carità
e riduciamo una distanza di 100 400
metri
facciamo in modo che la luce percorra
esattamente la stessa quantità di spazio
e sappiate i problemi non sono quando il
fotone sta attraversando in mezzo
interspaziali
mezzo interspaziale i problemi sono
fanno altro nell'atmosfera perché qui
hai una bolla d'aria fredda qui c'è una
cosa che avete presente le turbolenze
dell'aereo ecco il fotone passa
attraverso queste turbolenze e quindi un
po di cammino
va a farsi benedire abbiamo bisogno di
strutture che riescano a compensare
correggere per questo cammino e poi cosa
facciamo con vigna nel momento in cui
abbiamo questo possiamo combinare
insieme la luce che arriva da questi
oggetti da poi tutti questi telescope
yeti e ricostruire amplificare il nostro
segnale è ricostruire quella che era
l'informazione della sorgente da cui per
questi sistemi queste queste questi
queste infrastrutture che ci permettono
di avere tanti telescopi di compensare
per le luci si chiamano interferometri e
usano proprio quella che è la
caratteristica
della luce che la coerenza
ci sono vari interferometri in giro per
il mondo
perché li abbiamo costruiti cosa abbiamo
osservato cos'è che abbiamo imparato
grazie a l'interferometro soltanto la
coerenza della luce abbiamo ad esempio
osservato superfici di stelle
esattamente come abbiamo osservato il
nostro sole abbiamo imparato come la
luce si forma all'interno della sera
come viene trasportata lo sapevate che
per esempio la superficie di una stella
a delle bolle proprio come la prenditela
con l'acqua che bolle prima di metterci
la pasta
questa è la condizione
l'abbiamo osservata sulle stelle non
solo sul sole oppure avete vi immaginate
come ha fatto per esempio
come come si costruisce su questo
materiale di cui di cui di cui sono
fatte le cose che sono di cui che
abbiamo intorno come ho fatto ad
arrivare questa terra
abbiamo siamo riusciti a osservare come
si formano le polveri come si formano
verso i materiali pesanti e come il
vento stesa dell'eliporto
riporta nello spazio
abbiamo osservato
altri sistemi che una letale che si
stanno formando siamo riusciti
addirittura a osservare come come è
fatta la superficie di un altro pianeta
nel senso quali sono i materiali di cui
ho fatto a
jensen nel 2020 premio nobel ha usato
nei suoi studi proprio la coerenza della
luce tra le altre cose è riuscita a
dimostrare che al centro della nostra
terra e la centrale al centro della
nostra galassia
c'è un buco nero nello stesso modo
usando una serie di
antenne non antenne distribuite su un
campo da calcio ma distribuito su tutto
il globo
abbiamo siamo riusciti a
ottenere l'immagine di un buco nero in
un'altra galassia
il l'interferometria non è usata
soltanto in in astronomia viene anche
usata per studiare in oceanografia
viene usata come tecnica anche per
studiare la compattezza di una montagna
se esista pesava 20 giugno malaria o una
frana
è una tecnica che viene viene applicata
veramente
per osservare dettagli che in realtà
altrimenti sarebbero visibili e allora a
questo punto io vi chiedo pensate quanto
siamo potenti quando collaboriamo
abbiamo collaborato attraverso diversi
paesi diversi continenti per mettere
insieme questi
questi telescopi
abbiamo usato la coerenza che ci ha
promesso veramente a questo punto di
superare barriere e rendere visibile
anche ciò che al momento dei ai nostri
occhi
sarebbe stato completamente invisibile
[Applauso]